hey
welcome to geek culture explained hope
you're doing well in whatever part of
the world you are currently reciting
this is god i'm back at it with a brand
new editorial
so let's get right to it talking about
the colossal fumble that has been dc
films uh feels like low-hanging fruit at
this point right cause whether it's the
previous regime led by walter hamada the
merger with discovery david zazlab's
authoritarian approach the recent rumors
that dan lin is purportedly going to be
the future kevin feige of dc what is
there to say that hasn't already been
said actually here's a radical thought
david zazlaf
really may be the goat who else in the
history of nerd culture has gotten so
many people to care about an earnings
call
that ladies and gentlemen is pure
talent that's also how i knew that the
large hadron collider hurled us into a
very bleak dystopia there were nerds on
twitter waiting anxiously not for the
release of a new trailer or first look
but for an earnings call fun fact i plan
to reference the large hadron collider
on every single one of my editorials in
some form or fashion moving forward and
uh so far we are two for two but
obviously i'm being somewhat facetious
here because the reason that pop culture
fandom cared about that earnings call so
much was because they wanted a slither
of assurance that david zaslav had a
plan a vision for dc moving forward
which brings us to superman whom zazlab
has repeatedly expressed interest in
bringing to the forefront now superman
is a peculiar case because there's so
many people who claim that he's just an
op uninteresting boy scout yet so many
have opinions on who and how superman
should be i've even seen some make the
argument that homelander has overtaken
superman as a more compelling character
for our modern times another
depressingly fascinating aspect of the
character is the lengthy lineage he's
had in development hell on the film side
we can start with for example something
like superman lives which you may recall
was going to be directed by tim burton
with nicholas cage in the titular role
which by the way people often troll
cages look because of this picture but
in the context of the 90s and what tim
burton wanted to do
i'm actually not mad at the way nicholas
cage looks at superman in this picture
but if you're interested in learning
more about superman lives the late john
schnepp directed a documentary called
the death of superman lives that maybe
worth checking out for you there was
also the infamous superman flyby with jj
abrams at the helm you can scour the
internet to find a surprising amount of
details about that film and one idea
that i found interesting was how abrams
wanted to have jarrell
investigating jonathan and martha kent
on earth to see if they were even
suitable to raise kal-el to begin with
and there was also a bit of interesting
spillover when you consider something
like man of steel because abrams wanted
krypton to feel like a fully realized
world with its own language and you may
recall that henry cavill's superman suit
is actually etched with kryptonian
writing which again would suggest that
we got to witness some of flyby's ideas
even if the film itself was never able
to fly by the development process i'm
sorry i couldn't resist but this video
isn't about flyby ladies and gentlemen
this video is about christopher mcqueary
and his pitch for superman which would
have also opened the door for green
lantern in the dc eu as well now when
contrasted to something like superman
lives or flyby we know virtually nothing
about mcquarrie's vision there's no
concept art no pre-production stills no
script leaks
nothing
nada zip zero stingy with de niro the
only thing we know is that macquarie
made a pitch to warner brothers it would
have starred henry cavill tom cruise
would have
99.999 percent played hal jordan
and in fact macquarie and henry actually
proposed the film
together and that'll do it for this
video thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you all on the next
editorial no of course this is not the
end did you all think i was gonna leave
you on that anti-climatic note you think
so little of me so we don't know much
about mcquarrie's vision for superman
outside of what he shared in tweets that
have since been deleted but tweets are
like that last jedi quote they're never
really gone
in one tweet mcquarrie says that warner
brothers never cared for his original
ideas and just wanted him to fix their
broken ones he also says that warner
brothers didn't flat out say no they
just never moved or acted upon his pitch
and further mentions that this meeting
happened before the release of mission
impossible fallout which we'll come back
to later
it also appears that the bridge between
warner brothers and macquarie has been
irreparably damaged because he said that
he would not reconsider going back to
superman even if he was invited to do so
now this is where things get interesting
because like i said outside of those
tweets we know nothing about what
mcquarrie wanted to do with superman but
going through his filmography does give
us some interesting insights
the most obvious place to begin is with
this year's biggest hit top gun maverick
which mcqueary received a screenplay
credit for
given how maverick expertly catered to
the nostalgia of fans of the first film
and created a new generation of top gun
fans it's not outside the realm of
possibility that macquarie would have
aimed to do the same with superman and i
wholeheartedly believe he would have
been successful he would have created a
classical superman
and a modern one he would have given us
a classic modern superman what i mean by
that is he would have created an
interpretation of the character that
would have been less contentious and
more broadly accepted than zack snyder's
interpretation
by the way i'm actually a huge fan of
zack snyder and his vision for all dc
characters batman v superman is in my
top 5 all-time favorite cbms if that's a
conversation y'all want to have in a
future editorial let me know in the
comments below because there's people
who are actually lifelong fans of zack
snyder and that film based on my content
and coverage of it in the past i even
had ray fisher and zack snyder on a
podcast just two days after the snyder
cut was confirmed for hbo max
actually now that i think about it that
was zack's
first public appearance since the
snydercon announcement you know what let
me stop flexing and digressing now the
aerial sequences in top gun maverick are
also second to none i'll let your
imagination run wild with all the ways
macquarie would have explored superman's
flight in that regard because i don't
believe my words could even do that idea
or potential justice
which brings us to the mission
impossible series
now if you recall macquarie said that
him and henry made the pitch to warner
brothers prior to mi fallout coming out
there's something i vividly remember
about that film's release henry cavill
during that time on instagram i believe
had under a million followers
because i remember when fallout came out
a friend of mine was monitoring his
account and as soon as that movie was
released that is what we believe pushed
him over a million
and if i'm being delusional and not
remembering correctly his following in
general was relatively low for a guy
playing superman on the big screen but
when fallout came out it went higher
exponentially
higher
and then of course there was a witcher
announcement there was a report back in
2018 about him being out at superman but
then later that day he put out a video
with a caption quote today was exciting
superman then the witcher came out he
assembled his pc in a blue tank top and
the rest is history now let that
marinate for a moment ladies and
gentlemen henry's celebrity has actually
increased not by playing superman
but by
not playing superman so at that time him
and macquarie made that pitch to warner
brothers it's easy to see how the studio
could deny or overlook both of their
respective bargaining power whether
henry wanted more money more creative
control or the combination of both
warner brothers clearly did not take
them seriously and both of their stocks
have skyrocketed since when it's all
said and done christopher mcqueary will
have written and directed four mission
impossible films and coming off the
success of maverick it's highly likely
that mission impossible dead reckoning
will go on to break a billion at the box
office that's obviously going to be
because of tom cruise's momentum post
maverick but again christopher
mcqueary's stock continues to rise
whenever y'all get a chance go through
his catalog of films that he's either
written or directed especially
especially especially
the underrated masterpiece that was edge
of tomorrow with emily blunt and tom
cruise as i was recently doing a binge
of his catalogue it became so crystal
clear to me that he would have been the
ideal director and writer to entrust
with superman he would have nailed the
spectacle the action the emotion and the
cultural nostalgia of the character but
we'll never see it
so let me know your thoughts down below
in the comments after watching this
video do you equally feel confident that
macquarie would have been the ideal
individual to usher in a new era of
superman on film how familiar were you
with this catalog before this video how
intrigued are you by his catalogue after
this video it's interesting because i
was talking to a couple of people about
you know why i wanted to make this video
in the first place and uh their response
was that they didn't even know that
mcqueary wanted to make a superman film
to begin with and that's how i knew that
it would be an interesting and timely
conversation to have
especially when you consider everything
going on currently like we discussed
with warner brothers discovery and the
overall lack of any managerial stability
since the release of batman v superman
back in 2016. but if you enjoyed this
video make sure to hit that like button
and subscribe to geek culture explained
if you haven't already you can find me
on my youtube channel uh which at the
time of this video has uh
seven subscribers and uh zero videos uh
that's like when nba players have zero
points one rebound and six fouls as
their stat line but you know i've been
on this auto didactic uh filmmaking
journey over the past two years and uh
shout out to everyone who watched the
surviving hall h video shout out to rob
gordon and tc for essentially giving me
carte blanche with with that project uh
so i am planning on doing some things on
that channel that i feel could be
important in terms of you know
documenting the journey
of me trying to kind of get my first
film made
because it is a hellacious one and i
feel like every single day of my life i
wake up i feel like i'm either not good
enough or i'm too good or i'm developing
too fast or i'm not developing fast
enough it's a world wind of emotions
across the spectrum so yeah ladies and
gentlemen that'll do it for me um thank
you all so much for your time and i will
see you all on the next editorial